it's really important to note that
chappelle has said
you know actually in this special
himself that he's not making fun of
trans people um he's making fun of white
people he's very specific about who his
target is you know that he specifically
um is targeting white people and racism
in his and he's kind of putting trans
and people of color into a similar group
that they're both uh experiencing racism
or
uh bias and violence and uh getting the
short end of um the stick here in
society and i think
he's
kind of clear about that as well so
i i will
open this aperture now to a bigger
discussion which i think is are
are you getting the sense that
corporations have had enough of cancer
culture and virtue signaling
i wonder if
uh ted cerandos would have come out this
strong and said hey listen if he's
essentially saying if you don't like it
you should change the channel which i
remember when i was growing up it's
really interesting generationally how we
see things differently gen x when we
were raised
we were raised that absolutely freedom
of speech was such a critically
important tenet of a democracy that you
had to accept speech you did not agree
with that was offensive
and that part of the package of a free
society was that some amount
of free speech was going to be
uncomfortable and
you know if the ku klux klan wanted to
march down main street the aclu would
back them up and not because they agreed
with what they were saying but they
agreed with their right to say it that's
how our our generation gen z for the
millennials and the uh gen z's this is
how gen x was raised now it's really
interesting to watch millennials kind of
shift a little bit over and then
gen z shifting all the way over and
now you i think have the corporation
saying listen there's got to be
something more reasonable than canceling
dave chappelle whose body of work is
unbelievable he's the greatest comedian
uh on the planet today by far certainly
i think everybody would agree with that
you know if you asked a hundred
communities who the greatest comedian is
right now they would say dave chappelle
i mean they might make a joke but
they'd say me then dave chappelle
and so are we are we canceling dave
chappelle now i mean because
he clearly does not intend harm here but
it is clearly offensive to people so i
get that as well
and it relates to what we saw with brian
armstrong i think at coinbase he said
listen we're a mission-based company
and i talked about this on episode 1295
and all in episode 49. at the time
coinbase was like 10 billion now it's
worth like 50 60 billion he just said to
everybody if if you want to talk about
politics if you want to talk about any
of these charged issues do it on your
own time go find another company if you
don't like it some people walked he gave
them like a super generous
uh package when you're a company with
unlimited resources like they were tons
of cash in the bank
giving people an amazing severance
package is just a way to
make it for somebody who is unhappy to
say no like imagine right now
you are on a scale of one to ten a six
and how happy you are at your job if i
offer you two months of severance how
many people are saying yes however you
six months of severance and it's a six
for you how many people are saying
no to that deal like a hundred percent
of people who rate their experience at
work a five six or seven if they got a
six month or a year package they're out
and uh that's basically a new technique
i've seen in uh companies that are
dealing with these issues is just
make the exit package so strong that
people voluntarily opt out it's really
kind of savvy um you know for both
parties because you you create this exit
package that results in signing a
non-disclosure we agree that it's part
of this payment of six months salary
plus vesting your options a year
whatever it was
that you're going to you know not trash
the company on the way out quite
reasonable and and we won't trash you uh
because it will be reciprocal but what
brian armstrong was saying you know i
think was listen i just don't have the
energy to deal with cancer culture it's
a distraction and i think that's now
what uh netflix is saying to their
employees
listen i understand it some of these
things are going to be offensive
and we don't believe they're crushing
harm but we respect if you believe that
and if you do believe that
you as a customer you can change the
channel you can cancel your subscription
so they're putting a line in the same
with the customers we're not taking it
down if you don't like it don't watch it
there's other things you can watch
or you can cancel your subscription i
think that's what ted's saying here is
like listen you're an adult you signed
up for this paid we're not putting this
on the open airwaves this isn't like a
you know fcc issue where you know it's
on a public
airwave this you're paying and opting
into getting this so if you don't want
it don't pay us and he's saying to
employees if you don't want to be at a
company that
leans towards
uh the free expression uncomfortable
speech pushing boundaries in comedy
there's the door you know we'll hash it
out with you but if you're gonna stay
here you know this there's always going
to be something here uh that's going to
be controversial feelings will be heard
and
armstrong did a twitter thread about the
reaction and so as evidence piles up
that standing up to these issues or
saying hey we're not going to cancel
this person
we're drawing a line here now i think is
the the the trend we'll see so there's
always a pendulum in these discussions
and i think most people are getting a
little tired of the cancer culture
they're getting a little tired of the
virtual signaling i think that's why i
think trump actually ran on that right
like what's like part of trump's
positioning is like you know we're going
to be
bad boys and say what we want and you
can't cancel us and we're uncancible i
think that's kind of the appeal of joe
rogan too you know spotify is not
cancelling him
so now you have spotify
uh coinbase and netflix all saying look
here's the line we'll have a reasonable
discussion about content
but there's there's a line here we're
not getting rid of joe rogan we're not
getting rid of dave chappelle and you're
not going to come to work every day and
create a distraction and talk about
whatever the you know most charged issue
in the world is and we'll see if what
happens with apple i think apple's going
to be the real test case is apple gonna
say to their employees like enough
you know we're just not gonna comment on
israel versus palestine we're not going
to take a position
on certain things uh and
we'll see spotify um
you know did concede previously by
taking down the alex jones episode if
you remember alex jones of course uh was
um i think thrown off of every platform
for spreading disinformation and
slandering people and then he lost his
lawsuit against the sandy hook parents i
mean if you just think about
there's an example of content that
probably does create harm and you could
probably put a one-to-one to it right
like alex jones is
you know really spreading conspiracy
there is somebody who spreads conspiracy
varies over and over and over again i
think there is a reasonable
and attacks the parents of murder
children like it's so dark that i could
see spotify saying you know what
i can even see joe rogan saying like i
don't have a problem with it like i'll
take my money and yeah that episode's
supercharged we'll just leave it on
another platform because there is
something about platforming and that's
the larger issue are you giving people a
platform to spread this hate
or to spread misinformation
and again it's a nuance that's a nuanced
issue um when it comes to
comedy
people are kind of i think coming to a
decision that that's going to be a safe
space
for people to savings that are offensive
or maybe push the boundaries and i think
comedians are
going to stand their ground on this and
obviously netflix is as well so i don't
think it's the end to cancel culture
but i think
something is changing in corporations
where
they're just saying
we're going to have to put our foot down
at some point let's make this the hill
we're going to die on so the hill that
netflix is going to die on is chappelle
the hill that coinbase is going to die
on
is politics at work the hell that
spotify has chosen to die on or to fight
their last battle
is joe rogan and so i'm interested in
your thoughts on this
you cannot mention me on twitter by
jason
if you listen to twist often you've
heard me talk about odoo's suite of
business apps a lot and they are sweet
well they're going to give you your
first app free forever and a thousand
dollars off your implementation pack at
odoo dot com slash twist odo.com twist
and here is why odoo is amazing for
startups their suite of business apps
helps you run your entire company on one
platform and they will streamline the
workflows by bringing all your
information together eliminating
annoying repetitive tasks like entering
data across multiple platforms plus if
you only need two or three apps to
optimize your workflow at your startup
well that's all you'll pay for they're
not going to charge you for apps you
don't use of course not
and odoo offers 30 main apps that are
going to get almost everything in your
organization done plus 16 000 apps from
their open source community for those
niche applications that might be unique
to your business their apps include
bookkeeping sales crm website builders
and more so here is your cta the old
call to action again your first app is
free forever and odoo is offering 1 000
right now on your first implementation
pack get that credit right now before
it's gone odo.com
twist